so I just found out that Liam Payne died um
and it's a really complicated feeling right now
growing up I was a really big fan of one direction
really important part of my childhood
that being said
I have been caught up with all of the things that have been coming out about him
in the last few weeks um
so I just wanted to say
before this becomes crazy
have your feelings have your feelings about Liam
you can have your feelings about
you know being a fan of his
you know him being one direction
I understand he was a really big part of a lot of people's childhoods
that being said
leave Maya Henry alone
leave the woman that have spoken about him alone
other right now
this is what Maya Henry's comment section looks like
I genuinely could not imagine what that woman is going through right now
um absolutely unacceptable
like it's really unfortunate to be watching this happen in real time because
like regardless of your feelings about him
like this is a tactic of abuse
like things were coming out about him
I'm sure more things are gonna come out about him
and to escape responsibility like
and this also guarantees that his victims will have to be
even in his death
perpetually victimized by him and his actions and his stans and his fans
so you can have your feelings
but don't perpetuate the same abuse to his victims that he did
separate your feelings as a fan from their feelings as victims of abuse
I don't know just leave those women alone